tom waits says something about new york
you like tom weights i think he's
underrated i think he's got great he's
got a great uh he's great at quips and
quotes
check him out on youtube he's got some
montages and supercuts of him being
hilarious what does he say about um
i'd rather have a bottle in front of me
than a frontal lobotomy that was the one
that was the one that sold me i was like
this guy's awesome yeah but his music
because he's just a genius musician yeah
anyway he was talking about new york i
was walking around these i'm in new york
right now we're in new york right now
it's still a magical city to me a lot of
people are quite cynical about it about
the state of things but
like a lot of friends of mine they're
just a lot of folks in san francisco new
york there's something about the
pandemic where people have become
quite cynical about the place they are
and they try to escape
it's interesting i mean they're asking
some difficult questions about what they
are in life they're having like a
self-imposed midlife crisis is good i
think for everybody to go through this
process but i think i hope new york
reemerges
it will as the flourishing place for the
weirdos anyway the tom wade said new
york of course
is to be in endless surreal situations
where a 50 000 gunmetal mercedes pulls
up in a puddle of blood
and outsteps a 25 karat blonde with a
two dollar wristwatch
and he goes he keeps going on so like
it's like um
that's like bars he's like a rapper yeah
he's good
um
but basically just the absurdity of it
all lots of money lots of weirdos
uh degenerates and dreamers and the
whole the whole mix of it do you think
um
i think that's an accurate description
of what new york is today like is there
still place for the weirdos and just the
interesting artists
the the edgy the comedians the the
creators
the the
the entrepreneurs like
as opposed to like wall street as
opposed to like
rich folk
and then like
hopeless folk yeah i think it's
definitely changed a lot there's a
there's a tiny corner for us weirdo
artists new york used to be where you
went to make it as a painter or whatever
a comedian or a singer and there were
all these dives and [ __ ] boxes and all
these places you could go
and now there's now it's more
pinkberries and
subway sandwiches and chase banks so
it's definitely lost a lot of its uh
creative edge it's just money money
keeps coming in and now you see all
these comedians moved to nashville
austin denver whatever so uh
it doesn't have the the power it used to
have of like you got to be here if you
want to make it that's definitely gone
uh so
that hurt the city a lot the city is is
way more soulless
when i moved here in 07 i mean not only
did i get mugged three times in the
first year
but
it was a hub of like it felt like things
were happening here you know it was it
was an energy it was electricity and we
still have the electricity but it's also
maybe just because it's times square
there's soho there's uh wall street so
we got the staples but there is a little
bit of that it's almost like a marriage
like yeah we're in love but it's not as
passionate as it once was
that's how i would equate new york
what gives you hope you're pretty
hopeful about it though i'm hopeful just
because i know it's magical and i and i
think it has to be i mean it's the
epicenter of america like this is where
the immigrants came and this is where
the stock market is and the
entertainment industry a lot of it is
here so
i think it's it's gonna happen but it
all something like the bottom has to
fall out and then people have to move
back here and all that so something
the corporations are kind of [ __ ] us
they're just buying everything well
that's true for everything that's
awesome for everything oh it's true for
austin probably as well people just
buying out land and all that kind of
stuff you always hear a hemingway and
dali and all these guys went to paris
in the 20s or whatever that was
yeah i get it now i feel like why do
these guys go to paris you know what are
these
artists and now i get it because it's
like it's freer there that's why austin
became like that paris where everybody's
like i gotta get out of la i'm going
there
and uh
maybe but we came back from that you
know the 70s were wild and 90s were cool
so maybe it'll come back might just take
a decade well there's always that's how
stories are told there's always pockets
of
like
paris within new york right
there's just an opportunity to
let your weird flourish is there in new
york i'm sure they're i mean
um
it's there you gotta find it before it
was front and center
what's your favorite thing about new
york like what what kind of
things just like i mean how long is this
pod i could go on it's just it's too
much to
to put into one hour we've got other
questions but
i love that one neighborhood is wildly
different than the next i'm in little
italy and then you take four steps now
i'm in chinatown i mean and then the
history there and then the stories
and the food and the culture and all
that
and then you go ten feet over here now
you're in brooklyn and this is insane
there's a whole other world and it's
it's almost like a little america in one
you know uh city and it's great and uh
just the fact that they pulled it off
like
fifth avenue goes way up and you're like
there's a billionaire's house next to a
hobo and then this is a black guy who's
fighting with a cuban guy and an asian
guy's uh trying to get in the middle of
them and the cabbies from uh the middle
east and
there's so many beautiful women here and
there's so many brilliant minds here and
and the pace is great it keeps people
moving i mean it just you can't beat it
i mean the city will [ __ ] you in the ass
too don't get me wrong you landed jfk
and you're like oh god i got mugged my
uh my uber driver called me a homo i
stepped in and human [ __ ] where the [ __ ]
am i
um so yeah it's it's bad news but that
bad news it's almost like the bullying
it kills you in a weird way but it makes
you stronger and you build more layers
and layers and layers that's why some
new guys some hayseed from milwaukee
shows up you've been here 10 years and
you go let me let me help you out
because uh you're you you gotta adjust
you're gonna get your ass kicked for
like six months but i know the ropes a
little and uh i think you need a little
that if the treadmill is not on
you're not gonna run new york the
treadmill's on so it just makes you run
and it makes you better look it wears on
you you probably lose 10 years of your
life living in new york versus
uh you know indianapolis but
it's a you know it's a better life have
you seen 25th hour yeah
um spike lee joint yeah sparkly joy i
mean uh at norton
there's a there's a whole like monologue
there about
they're talking about
just he he has like a mix
it's there's like melancholy music i
think or just a melancholy feel to the
whole thing but there's an anger and a
disgust with the city but through the
anger and the disgust comes out like a
love for the city same with was taxi
driver in new york oh yeah
crazy
yeah so like that there's something
about what is that what is that that uh
grit
of the city
that
like
pushes you down well that's the beauty
of the city is it's this tribal human
nature like the
sex shops and fist fights and racism and
all tension but yet it's the epicenter
of technology and finance and
sophistication on fifth avenue so you
get that
juxtaposition
it's kind of like in boston you go to
boston they got mit they got harvard
they got all this [ __ ] and then they got
the fishermen the blue-collar douchebags
the irish guys the immigrants you know
and you get that mix of like insanely
smart with wicked pissa and these these
two worlds and that's that's a good
thing it's like when a black guy [ __ ]
an asian lady that's a good-looking kid
you get a mix you know we're mixing two
totally different things they're coming
together and it makes it it's like
peanut butter and chocolate
peanut butter and chocolate i've never
tried that what peanut butter maybe i
have
talked about reese's like reese's evan
yeah yeah oh it's the best candy yeah
without the fakeness of la without the
without the kind of um
with the facade yeah at least tough
you